Robert Pattinson might be running into a big
issue while preparing for The Batman.
In a recent YouTube stream, Beyond the Trailer's
Grace Randolph disclosed that sources close
to the film's production are reporting that
the actor is having trouble packing on the
necessary pounds for the role.
Randolph said,
"I've heard that Robert Pattinson is having
a little bit of trouble bulking up.
I think it's probably impossible for him to
fully bulk up because he just has a slight
build, but I think it's hilarious they are
like, 'Maybe if we gave him a few more weeks,
he might bulk up'.
If he hasn't bulked up by now, he's not going
to bulk up.
Just accept you have skinny Batman and deal
with it."
We feel the need to point out a couple of
things here.
First, Randolph's sources are anonymous, meaning
that their degree of involvement in The Batman
might be intimately involved or not involved
at all, or anything in between.
Pattinson hasn't popped up in public at any
point super-recently, so we have no idea if
he's gotten extremely jacked for The Batman,
which is in pre-production and is thought
to be going before the cameras early next
year.
Second, it's worth remembering the role that
Christian Bale played immediately prior to
his debut as the caped crusader in Batman
Begins.
He appeared as the extremely troubled, physically
and psychologically fragile title character
in The Machinist, a role for which he lost
enough weight to pose an actual danger to
his health.
Bale looked like a skeleton in that movie,
and just a year later, he was convincingly
playing the big, buff Dark Knight.
Now, Bale and Pattinson are obviously different
people, so it's entirely possible that the
latter could be having some difficulty packing
on the muscle while the former did not.
All we're saying is that the fact Pattinson
has a "slight build" doesn't mean anything
at all, and there's a strong possibility that
his reported struggle with bulking up is completely
fabricated.
In fact, if you ask us, this report has the
suspicious ring of a rumor floated by parties
who don't think that Pattinson has what it
takes to fill out Batman's cape and cowl.
We'll concede that there isn't much in his
previous filmography to suggest that he has
the type of physical presence required to
portray the Caped Crusader.
Still, if you're mostly familiar with the
actor from his work as sparkly vampire Edward
Cullen in the Twilight series, then you should
know that his casting was no left-field choice.
"It's because you believe the lies.
It's camouflage.
I'm the world's most dangerous predator."
Pattinson is a serious actor, as he's demonstrated
in critically acclaimed indie films like Good
Time and High Life since his brush with franchise
fame.
If you need a higher-profile, extremely recent
example of his formidable chops, look no further
than The Lighthouse.
The psychological thriller from director Robert
Eggers is currently drawing critical acclaim
from across the board, and the stark, black-and
white period tale of two lighthouse keepers
slowly driving each other mad is largely a
two-man show.
Those two men are Pattinson and Willem Dafoe,
and if the general critical consensus is to
be believed, the younger actor more than holds
his own opposite a man known far and wide
for giving intense, committed performances.
Since we've gone this far, let's edge all
the way out onto our limb here in suggesting
that the most prominent actors to portray
Bats in the modern era Michael Keaton in Tim
Burton's films, Bale, and Ben Affleck in the
early DC Movie Universe efforts were hamstrung
by not being the most important characters
in their own movies.
The Batman, as its title indicates, is shaping
up to be Pattinson's show.
Even if the flick's director Matt Reeves builds
a tremendous rogues' gallery around him, Pattinson
has the opportunity to give us a version of
Batman that would be truly groundbreaking.
We'll be able to find out for sure when The
Batman hits screens on June 25, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.